[Musique]
ma
ce que nous avons fait, nous avons utilisé
des cellules de plants de café
et les avons produites dans des bioréacteurs
pour finalement en faire une véritable infusion de café
[Musique],
nous effectuons actuellement une analyse complète de l'ACL
de l'ensemble du processus, ce qui signifie  l'
analyse du cycle de vie
et pour vraiment regarder quelle est l'
empreinte environnementale par exemple, donc ce que
nous savons déjà, c'est que bien sûr
notre empreinte eau, par exemple, est
bien inférieure à ce qui est nécessaire dans
la croissance du champ
[Musique]
par rapport au café ordinaire qui  nous avons choisi
pour cela cela dit que le café cellulaire est
moins amer c'est en partie dû à la plus faible
teneur en caféine dans le café cellulaire
[Musique]
alors il y a bien sûr différents en
arôme
ils sont
peut être moins prédominants dans le fruité
moins prédominants dans l'intensité du
givré  commander et ainsi de suite
périphérique méta
[Musique]
vous